tante a construit merci madame la parole
les temps monsieur sylvain berrios
avec jacques alain bénisti les élus
parisiens je vois que le goas guen et
philippe goujon les 130 maire de la
métropole du grand paris mon chien
patrick ollier les élus franciliens je
m'adresse à vous comme d'ultimes porte
parole au sujet de la fermeture des
voies sur berge à paris le 21 juin
dernier quand je vous ai interrogé j'ai
hâte et aux jeunes à mme royal la
réponse a été tout changement qui
bouscule les habitudes
nécessite des débats démocratiques
que reste-t-il du débat démocratique
lorsque la mère de paris piétine
l'avis négatif du commissaire enquêteur
un périmètre dans qu'être réduit des
problèmes économiques de transport de
sécurité voilà ce que chacun sait déjà
mais surtout le commissaire enquêteur a
pointé de report de pollution qui vont
asphyxier la rive gauche et l'est
parisien nous avons une chance
historique de travailler à la réduction
de la pollution aux particules finir en
ile-de-france qui tuent chaque année des
milliers de personnes
vérité crès la région ile de france ont
mis en place un comité scientifique sur
la qualité de l'air or le gouvernement
vos services refuse de fournir des
études trafic des voies rapides et des
autoroutes a4 a86 à 13 avant et après la
mise en place si les nuisances ne sont
pas avérés pourquoi refuser de
transmettre des données pourquoi cacher
que le projet rendant l'air irrespirable
pour des milliers de franciliens la
pollution ne s'arrête pas aux
périphériques il n'y a pas un rideau
magique
la santé d'enfants de banlieue vaut
celle d'un enfant parisien la décision
définitive revient au préfet de police
qui est placé sous l'autorité du
gouvernement c'est pourquoi nous
demandons un moratoire immédiat à une
nouvelle enquête publique élargie à
l'ensemble des communes concernées
monsieur ministre ou ce qui reste du
gouvernement aujourd'hui la sente plaît
nous attendons de réponse la parole est
monsieur alain vidalies secrétaire
d'état chargé des transports dans la mer
et de la pêche
mais merci monsieur le président
monsieur le député je partage avec vous
le constate comme tous les français
celui que la dégradation de la qualité
de l'air est chaque année responsable et
vous l'avez cité de milliers de décès et
de beaucoup de maladies graves notamment
respiratoires et vous le savez ce
chiffre ne cesse d'augmenter ce n'est
pas une situation uniquement parisienne
ou ile de france c est un phénomène que
l'on constate dans l'ensemble des
grandes villes avec des réponses qui
sont des réponses différentes parfois un
péage parfois des décisions en matière
de développement des transports en
commun il n'est pas dans l'intention du
gouvernement de faire la différence
entre le problème des personnes de l'île
de france ou de celle de paris c'est un
problème qui est largement partagé mais
il ya une seule chose que je veux vous
le dire compte tenu du bon stage je
pense que vous serez d'accord l'inertie
n'est pas une option nous ne pouvons pas
continuer à ne rien faire ou à remettre
en cause parce que ya des difficultés
immédiatement toute initiative qui
répond à une question majeure de santé
publique et donc c'est pas une surprise
puisque ça fait partie du débat
démocratique
la mairie de paris madame hidalgo
s'était engagé sur cette question devant
les électeurs le résultat de sa décision
est conforme à ses engagements le
gouvernement qui doit intervenir comme
vous l'avez dit dans cette affaire est
attentif avec le préfet de police et a
souhaité mettre en place pour une
période de six mois un comité
d'observation et je vous répond très
clairement toutes les données seront
transmises à qui le voudra pour que nous
puissions prendre ensemble les mesures
d'adaptation si c'est nécessaire la
réversibilité si elle s'impose dans tous
les cas nous ne pouvons pas rester sans
rien faire et le gouvernement soutient
l'initiative de la mairie de paris
merci